a 77-year-old man had enough of climate
activists in Panama blocking the road so
he did what probably many people want to
do in these situations and shot two of
them dead for his actions Kenneth
Darlington was not only arrested but has
gone viral to the implicit and explicit
cheers of many conservatives who are
rightly frustrated by climate activists
Shenanigans such as shutting down
roadways preventing parents from taking
their children to the hospital even and
attacking Priceless art but of course
darlington's vigilantism is not actually
Justified you don't just get to shoot
people for inconveniencing you no matter
how annoying they are and yet
darlington's actions are entirely to be
expected